good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast boris johnson is facing calls
to cut the self-isolation period for
people who test positive for covid to
just five days to protect the nhs and
the economy under current rules in
england people need to isolate for a
week but with nhs staff absences on the
rise experts say cutting the
self-isolation period could prevent
essential services from collapsing
meanwhile hundreds of thousands of
people will be contacted again this week
and urged to book a booster and have
what the health service is calling a
jabby new year let's speak to our
political correspondent joe pike who's
in westminster good morning joe so
how likely is it that they are going to
cut the isolation period to five days
and if they do when would it happen
i think it is kimberly increasingly
likely that this will happen because so
many medical and scientific experts are
recommending it although not the jcvi
quite yet they are the key body that
would press the government suggested the
government that they should change the
policy it would also make sense for the
government to announce it before the new
year of course the challenge at the
moment is we are seeing a very high case
rate a record number in england
yesterday 117 000 that would therefore
suggest there will also be record
numbers of people in self isolation one
recent estimate suggests
around 800 000 people could be self
isolating
in the uk
now the effects of that on the economy
on different public services is maybe
slightly muted now because of the
christmas uh break it's not affecting
schools it's not affecting some
businesses commuting is not
at
the height we'd expect expect next week
but that could obviously change we could
see staff shortages in train companies
in schools what will that mean for
pupils well some need to be
taught at home the key concern of course
though is as ever the nhs for the
government they are now slightly calmer
about how omicron will affect
hospitalizations we're certainly not
seeing the critical care search we saw
in january and february and one body nhs
providers which represents uh clinical
commissioning groups and nhs trusts says
that their bigger concern is not
actually omnicron's effect on
hospitalizations but omicron's effect on
staffing and self-isolation that could
be a bigger problem the nhs not able to
deliver the services it currently does
because of staff shortages this is the
view of the health minister jillian
keegan
we very recently went from 10 days to
seven days so today if you test negative
on day six and day seven then your
isolation period will end so that's what
we've done for now and of course we'll
await if jcvi want to give us further
advice on that then we'll uh we'll await
their advice
as julian keegan was saying there it was
just a week ago the uk government's
advice uh moved from 10 days
self-isolation to just seven as long as
you take a lateral flow test on day six
and on day seven and you test negative
in the u.s though that self-isolation
period if you test positive for covert
is now just five days and some uh within
uh the health service in this country
say we should start treating this as a
common cold we shouldn't uh see the
economy grind to a whole just because
people get
this
virus especially as some people are
getting
symptomatically or with very few
symptoms so can be i think it's
increasingly likely we will see a change
and it would make sense for that change
to happen pretty fast
okay joe thanks a lot
well let's have a look at the latest
covert 19 data now and there have been
129
471 new cases of covet 19 recorded in
the uk in the latest 24-hour period more
than 117 000 of those were in england
that's the highest number of cases
reported in england since the start of
the pandemic however those numbers do
not include data for scotland and
northern ireland but there is data for
wales which also includes figures from
christmas day and boxing day another 18
deaths have been reported within 28 days
of a positive test and that brings the
total number of people who've died in
the uk to 148 021.
well 16
357 people have received their first
dose of a vaccine and 18
965 have had their second now it means
in total nearly 47.3 million people have
received their second dose
well meanwhile 215 703 new boosters or
third jabs were reported in the latest
24-hour period nearly 32.7 million
people have now had their third jab or
their booster
well in europe omikron's surge across
the continent is forcing countries into
tighter restrictions france reported
europe's highest ever number of newly
new daily covert cases recording 179
807 cases on tuesday
however the figures could be due in part
reporting delays over christmas earlier
this week french health authorities did
warn that the country could see as many
as a quarter of a million cases a day by
the start of january the omicron variant
has also led to record high cases in
italy greece and portugal
the former children's commissioner for
england says the social care system is
not fit for purpose and frequently
places young people in greater danger
and longfield's commission on young
lives reports suggests the system is
guilty of handing some children over to
criminal gangs together with the oasis
charitable trust they're calling on the
government to establish a ministerial
task force aimed at financing new
community homes for children discuss
jared tubb reports yeah i'm actually
staying at my birth parents house
currently
rachel has been through the care system
in england which a new report says is
unfit for purpose
she says she saw increasing numbers of
older teenagers coming into care not
getting enough support and turning to
crime
i almost found myself almost joining
them because it was like well if all the
foster children are doing this let's
just be the stereotype but obviously at
that point i was trying to still go to
university so i prevented myself but
a lot of young people fall into that
trap just because it is a stereotype and
there's not that support so what else
can they actually do
the care system in england is said to be
facing an ongoing epidemic of drug
running grooming and serious youth
violence
the claims are made in a charity funded
report that says in march this year
there were 80
850 children in care in england up one
percent from last year
23 percent of them were 16 and 17 year
olds with acute needs
in london alone there were at least 1
932 children in care living in
unregulated semi-independent
accommodation
the report highlights older teenagers
being put in care to safeguard them from
county lines and criminal exploitation
only to end up at risk of more serious
harm it says the care system is
infuriatingly inadequate and was
designed with younger children in mind
we are seeing a children's social care
system which is um stretched to its
limits and creaking there is a
children's social care review going on
an independent review and we would like
that review to put teenagers very high
on its list of recommendations when it
reports early in
2022 it's completely unsustainable
either on moral grounds or economic
grounds which is why it needs to be
reset
much more towards helping children
before they get into crisis
the report shows particular concern for
racial bias that it says puts black boys
at particular risk of harm black
children are more likely to be in care
but the number who were adopted dropped
by 50 percent between 2015 and 2019
the report calls for a new care system
geared to help vulnerable teenagers
rachel says she was one of the lucky
ones
and supports the report's conclusion
that the current system is failing to
give teenagers the help they need
gerard tub sky news oldham
there's a warning today that millions of
families are facing a cost of living
catastrophe in 2022 due to soaring
energy bills and rising taxes emma
birchley joins us now from the newsroom
morning emma tell us a bit more about
this report yeah it's a pretty bleak
warning that comes from the economics
think tank the resolution foundation
that predicts that 2022 will be the year
of the squeeze and certainly many
families will be feeling that already
and
they say that inflation come the spring
could have hit six percent which would
be the highest it's been since 1992 and
it's really a perfect storm that's going
to kick in come april of two things and
that is soaring energy prices but also
tax rises so if we first off look at
energy price rises come april the
energy price cap will be increased and
for the typical family that's expected
to cost about
500 pounds and then when taxes the
national insurance contributions will
increase by 1.25 percent income tax
thresholds have been frozen and all
together this is expected to amount to
around 1
200 pounds for the typical family now
the government says they've taken
decisive action to try to help uh they
have put in measures worth 4.2 billion
pounds
they say the energy price cap is
protecting people from the real soaring
costs of wholesale energy
and on top of that they have also
increased the point at which universal
credit is reduced however the fact is
that resolution foundation says that the
government needs to do more and the
priorities should be tackling these
energy price rises
okay emma thank you very much
well joining me now is the shadow work
and pension secretary jonathan ashworth
mr ashworth good morning to you thanks a
lot for talking to us 1200 pounds extra
a year that's a lot of money
huge amount of money
working people families pensioners are
facing a devastating cost of living
crisis
it's because we've had 11 years of tory
economic failure we've now got this
low growth high tax
economy and what it means for families
and pensioners and working people is
that the heating bills are going through
the roof the prices in the shops are
going up because we've got inflation
back which also risks eroding savings
and pensions
and of course we've got these punishing
tax rises
on the way and wages are stagnating and
of course there's things like the
universal credit being cut which means
families are struggling struggling to
make
ends meet even when they're working all
hours god sends they're still in poverty
so this is a crisis we need action for
ministers like cutting v80 on fuel
unless we get that action working people
families pensioners are going to have a
very difficult year really squeezed
they're going to be worse off
well the government would probably argue
that it's because of two years of a
pandemic
and the rising energy costs that they
have just no control over
well especially soon like in boris
johnson who are imposing that big tax
rise this april on working people
alongside other taxis going up like
council tax it's richie sunak and boris
johnson who have cut the universal
credit for millions of families who are
who our restaurant has vanished she's
doing nothing to tackle the rising
energy costs so there is a different way
to this don't go ahead with that tax
rise let's get rid of the vat on our
heating bills let's have a proper
national living wage there are things
you can do to make people better off but
they'd argue that the tax rises are
because of the situation in which we
find ourselves that they have no control
over and they'd argue that they are
protecting people from those rising
energy costs with the energy price cap
look people as this think tank report
has shown today people are going to be
paying hundreds and hundreds of pounds
extra in energy bills and boris johnson
is nowhere to be seen he's not getting a
grip of this crisis he could take vat
off the energy bills that would cushion
uh cushion this for many many families
in fact you can have families worse off
you can have pensioners who are now
facing the prospect of uh shivering in
the cold or going without hot meals
because of these rising uh these rising
the price cap is protecting people
the people are still gonna be paying
hundreds of pounds more that's what the
think tank report today has is
demonstrating and we're suggesting like
other european countries are doing take
the tax take the vat off those few bills
fuel bills to get us through this crisis
and do other things like not going ahead
with the punishing tax rise this april
pay people a proper national living wage
because otherwise this is going to be a
year of squeeze this is a devastating
cost of living crisis the families
working people and pensioners and boris
johnson is nowhere to be seen on this he
cannot abduct his responsibilities to
ordinary working people like in the way
he is doing it's just not on
let's talk about covert now and this
issue of the isolation period it was ten
days it's been cut to seven and there
are calls and hour pressure on the pm to
cut it to five what do you think about
that well look i think we should always
follow the advice of our of our leading
scientists medical scientists like the
chris whittie and patrick valance and i
don't think they've given an opinion
on this the only thing i would say is
that
and i was listening to chris hopson
who's from who represents nhs chief
executives last night who was just
raising a question with respect to nhs
staff and we know the nhs is under huge
pressure because they haven't got enough
staff i mean we went into the crisis
short of 100 000 staff short of 40 000
nurses in the nhs he just he just made
the point that look nhs staff are
working
looking after some of the most
vulnerable people in society but for
that people who themselves have covered
whether that's patience in mental health
in patient units or even people in
community care settings they're looking
after very vulnerable people and their
duty is to protect those people so he
just raised a question about this
five-day
suggestion but i think we we should be
we should be led by our scientific
leaders by chris whittie and patrick
valence they are leading world leading
scientists let's see what they say on
this before rushing into this
so do you think if the jcvi if the um
the medical the chief scientific advisor
say yes go ahead with the five day as
they have done in the u.s five-day
isolation period you think we should go
ahead well i i'm not a medical scientist
so i would always uh uh
bow to their judgment in these
situations so i think so let's wait and
see what they have to say about it
i mean you know as always with these
things there's different there's
different opinions so we should those
politicians should always be careful to
listen to scientific experts
do you think we should have had tighter
restrictions before christmas before new
year
but we said nobody wanted to see
restrictions i think i think what we're
seeing with this
new variant is that if you get the
booster and you are vaccinated it gives
you a level of protection against it and
i think the question for me is why are
there still around five million people
who are not vaccinated on what are the
government going to do to get to those
five million people should they be going
door-to-door for example should we be
getting gps like we've actually had here
in leicester ringing them up directly
asking them to come in for their vaccine
i think if we we've got to go further on
vaccination to give our society greater
protection because we know that a huge
number of people in hospital sadly with
the new variant or indeed we've covered
anyway
are people who are not even vaccinated
and i think we need a big national
effort now to find that those missing
five million and persuade them to take
the job
okay mr ashrae thank you so much for
talking to us
pleasure
let's have a look at some other stories
making the news this morning and prince
andrew's lawyers have challenged his
sexual abuse accusers residency status
in a bid to have her civil case against
him thrown out of court the duke of
york's team have filed a motion that
states virginia geoffrey is not a u.s
citizen as she lives in perth in
australia and therefore the new york
court doesn't have jurisdiction over the
case miss geoffrey is suing prince
andrew for allegedly sexually assaulting
her when she was a teenager claims that
he strenuously denies
more than four million pounds of
taxpayers money was spent policing
insulate britain's road blocking
protests this year that's according to a
new investigation the transport
secretary grant shaps said he was
appalled by the bill which was disclosed
by police forces in response to freedom
of information requests
the legendary american football coach
and commentator john madden has died at
the age of 85 the nfl said he died
unexpectedly but didn't give a cause
madden led the oakland raiders to their
first super bowl in the 1976 season and
it became a hugely popular tv analyst
after retiring from coaching and nfl
video games have borne his name since
1988.
now the parents of a teenager who was
shot and killed by a stray bullet fired
by police in los angeles
have spoken of their pain at opening her
christmas presents without her body
camera footage shows the moment police
officers fired at a man who was
attacking people in a shopping center
valentino oriana peralta was hiding in a
changing room when a bullet hit her
through a wall
a warning this report from lisa holland
shows the moments before and after the
shooting
america is used to tragic shootings but
the family of valentina orlana peralta
say they are in disbelief that a
shopping trip to buy clothes for
christmas could have ended like this
the 14 year old was with her mother
soledad who described through a
translator how they were tragically
caught up in a police operation to stop
an attacker in a los angeles department
store
she died in my arms
and there was nothing i could do
to see
a son or daughter die in your arms
is one of the pains the greatest pains
and most profound pains that any human
being can imagine
[Applause]
police body cameras show officers
attending the store the day before
christmas
a man later identified as daniel ilana
lopez is seen attacking several female
customers with his bike lock
police shoot dead the attacker
but one of their bullets pierces a
changing room wall killing
fourteen-year-old valentina with a
gunshot wound to the chest
valentina's family say they came to los
angeles to escape violence in chile her
father showed reporters a christmas
present she never received through their
lawyer he spoke of his devastation
it is like my whole heart
has been ripped out of my body
the pain of opening the christmas
presents
for her
that had been delivered for christmas
day
cannot be articulated
my daughter was special
she had dreams
and tragically those dreams
have been overshadowed by this nightmare
that prevents me from sleeping at night
valentina's parents say they have
unanswered questions
about the way their daughter died
police shootings in los angeles have
more than doubled over the last 12
months the california department of
justice says it's now investigating lisa
holland sky news
let's have a quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
we're in for an unsettled week with more
wind and rain but it is going to turn
very mild northern and eastern britain
are frosty with some dense fog patches
while ireland northern ireland and the
southwest are mild wet and windy rain
there will clear during the morning with
sunny spells developing while northern
and eastern england and much of scotland
will turn wet some heavy rain is likely
over western hills while strengthening
winds in the south and west wilburn
gales to northwestern coasts it is going
to be mild generally chilly in the far
north northern scotland will turn wet
and very windy later but the strong
winds and rain will become largely
confined to the northern isles
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so 2021 has been a bumper year in the
world of tech with everything from
foldable phones and cryptocurrencies to
lfts and virtual reality becoming more
important than ever in today's world
joining me now with a review of what's
happened and what could be coming next
year is the global editor in chief of
tech radar gareth beavis gareth good
morning to you so
where do we even start
well it has been a very big year for
tech um not least because the fact that
pandemic is still obviously going on and
people are still struggling to know
exactly what to buy when to buy and
where to buy it but the big i think the
big headline has really been virtual
reality and it's been a bit of a stealth
one because i think most people have
been waiting for virtual reality yeah
tipping point everyone starts using when
there's a headset in every single lounge
across the country and it's not quite
there yet but there's really getting to
a tipping point where the oculus quest 2
for instance a headset that's come from
facebook is really starting to make
waves and people are really enjoying the
world of virtual reality in new ways
do you think that we will see a time
when there are headsets in every house
well this is what's exciting because yes
is the answer and it won't just be every
house it will be um things that we wear
on the streets but yeah i've been doing
this job a long time and you will start
predicting something you know 10 years
ago and then you see what actually comes
out it's it's a slightly watered down
version of it and it's less exciting but
it does proliferate through our society
and so i think that you know in 2022 if
and when apple does launch apple glasses
which are heavily rumored that will
change the game we've been saying that
for a few years but the idea is that
this technology really needs to work and
to be useful and not just a gimmick and
i feel like we're getting to the point
now where technology is giving us the
capability to have
um more lens technology that can sense
where our hands are in real space which
using things like lidar which would mean
that it actually works that i think when
that tipping point comes we will start
to really enjoy what what new things can
happen
so what would appleglass do
well this is the thing the the
idea would be simplicity basically you
don't want to go straight away with tens
of thousands of different things in
front of you you know facebook's doing
the metaverse trying to make things like
horizon worlds where there's just quite
a lot of information just thrown at you
in one sec
so what apple really needs to do is to
make sure that there's information
that's just useful so if you happen to
be nearby something that it knows a
notification we're popping up for that
would come up and hopefully quite
discreetly and like i said using um the
lasers and lidar technology you'll be
able to see where your hands are in real
time so you can interact with these
different interfaces without having to
tap the side of your glasses or to do
scrolling and do things that are quite
cumbersome that's the difference and
that's what's going to make the game
changing moves
let's talk about gimmicks and foldable
phones do you think they're gimmicks or
are they going to stay
they're absolutely going to stay and
they are very much not a gimmick the the
issue is right now is that people like
samsung are going very hard and trying
to make them mainstream we saw the
galaxy fold too which was an excellent
phone it was very thick it folded out
that way um it took a lot of it was
basically very heavy it wasn't the most
sleek device you could slip into your
pockets now the reason for this is that
the companies every phone company loves
battery space it loves being able to
stick a huge battery in as much as
possible so it doesn't have to worry
about charging all the time and that's
what samsung did with the galaxy fold
but what we're starting to see now is a
acceleration towards miniaturization
things like waterproofing and styluses
being added into the galaxy fold three
uh clamshell designs are becoming
important so not just folding things out
but things that you can snap shut and
they're much more useful for for just if
it's slipping in the pocket those are
coming and i've been tracking foldable
devices for 15 years and you know i saw
some startups in in eindhoven back in
the early 2000s and they were doing
great things in terms of roll out
displays and fold them out and half the
problem is just making sure that people
are ready for them because there's a
worry that they're more fragile they're
not going to work as well and while
there's a lot to do with technology
making these displays last for a long
time again making them less heavy they
are very exciting they're going to open
up a whole world of possibilities and
hopefully 2022 is going to see some some
real advances there
well none of it's going to work is it if
we don't have any chips and that
continues to be a problem
it really does and it it's really dull
unfortunately it's not one of those
things that um you want to talk about
because you want to talk about the
things they can do but absolutely the
chip shortages uh one of the most
annoying headlines of 2021 and the
reason for these are myriad there's um
the fact there's been weather issues in
japan and in america that of course
caused slowdowns i mean the pandemic
absolutely had a huge effect on it
we're thinking single digit percent
growth for the semiconductor industry
which which is the industry that makes
these chips uh we were expecting that to
be if a single digit in 2020 but that
was triple digit nearly 30 percent of
demand so that absolutely completely
changed everything and now every single
water industry wants to have neither
chip you know cars they can't make as
many cars now having to slow down
because there aren't the chips to put in
there the ps5 you can't get those
because you can't get as many chips
graphics cards there's so many things
and even
the smaller industries that rely on
these they just they just can't get them
because bigger orders and bigger
customers that need them in greater
volumes and so while there are huge
moves
being made to try and speed this up and
across the world and opening more
foundries not just in asia to try and
spread the load
they're two or three years away so we're
going to be here for a little while
oh that's a bit depressing but gareth
thanks a lot thanks anyway have a good
day
bye
now campaigners say thousands of
offenders are still serving indefinite
sentences despite the fact they were
abolished almost a decade ago the jail
terms called imprisonment for public
protection sentences were handed down
when a court believed an offender was a
danger to the public so no date was set
for their release skies aisha's head
reports
at 26 john was sentenced to a minimum of
five years in prison for armed robbery
but more than a decade later marie has
been forced to face another christmas
without her son as far as i'm concerned
john isn't dangerous he's traumatized
and there's no support he phoned me up
one christmas and he said to me mum
i can't do it anymore
i'm on a hunger strike
so i'm saying look john that ain't gonna
help you need to keep your strength up
you need to eat so
everybody the family
no one could eat our christmas dinner
that was done we're all crying john's
crying down the phone on many occasions
i live in fear that i'm gonna get the
phone call he's died
john was given an indeterminate
imprisonment for public protection
sentence or ipp in
2005. he was initially released after
serving nine years but has been recalled
twice since meaning he served a decade
over his original tariff
ipps were rolled out for offenders
considered to be a serious threat
introduced in 2005 they were later
abolished in 2012 but there was no
retrospective change for those who had
already been sentenced
over 8 700 ipps were issued and more
than one thousand seven hundred of those
prisoners are still incarcerated
the mental health crisis among these
prisoners is rife
ipp sentences have led to
hope a sense of hopelessness
and have been traumatic and in many
instances toxic
to the mental health of prisoners
and resulting in serious self-harm and
deaths
so far 70 ipp prisoners have taken their
own life tommy nickel is one of them my
brother wouldn't be dead today if he
wasn't he hadn't been given an ipv
sentence i have absolutely no doubt in
my mind about that
um
[Music]
he said it himself
donna is campaigning for change
the government has spent 10 years
trying to for the moj to try and fix
this and they've tried
but we still have a massive problem
the only way to fix this is through
re-sentencing and if they don't
re-sentence they need to and it needs to
be
there needs to be political change
around the license conditions
in a statement the ministry of justice
said we are helping those still in
custody progress towards release but as
a judge deemed them to be a high risk to
the public the independent parole board
must decide if they are safe to leave
prison
marie so desperately wants to see her
son back but the weight feels endless
she fears it could be many more years
before they're reunited aisha zahid sky
news
and anyone who's been affected by that
report or is emotionally distressed can
contact the samaritans for support
that's one one one six one two three or
on email just email joe at
samaritans.org
hello again you're watching sky news
breakfast we're gonna have a look at the
papers now journalist and author yazman
alibay brown and sociologist ashley
frawley are with us to do that hello
again to you both um
yasmine let's start with you and look at
the inside of the mail who is saying
we're over the worst of covid
well
i remain very cautious um
and i fear that this this double spread
um
is wishful thinking i think
what do they call it confirmation bias
that a lot of stuff is said here
um a leading expert says days of mass
fatalities are history well yes as
ashley said in the last
um uh
uh
review we did earlier
people aren't on ventilators we aren't
seeing the horrific scenes we used to
see um with the first
terrible
crisis that that erupted but you know i
do not believe that we're in in uh you
know in the sunny medal of meadows again
and some of the quotes here for example
sir john bell who's a senior scientist
says
very cautiously
um it is likely this will be less severe
and we will probably be fine
probably
in know cautious talk
one of the things that worries me about
this that people who are already not
masking and not being vaccinated will
now think it's over
and infection rates are rising so i'm
extremely cautious
but this is what the mail
is kind of almost celebrating
ashley what do you think do you think
that we should be cautiously optimistic
or do you think we should wait for the
data
well i think some of the data is is
coming in now and there are reasons for
cautious optimism i disagree that this
means that people will throw caution to
the wind in fact some of the reasons why
the numbers may have case numbers might
have fallen slightly around christmas is
because people were probably being very
very careful on the lead up to christmas
knowing that they're going to meet with
family members and so on and perhaps
meet with older people i think people
are at a point now where they know when
they are able to make judgments on the
basis of the information available i
think we should trust people to do that
and i also think we should avoid covet
tunnel vision too i mean yes we do have
to be cautious but there are other
things in society that need to be
worried about as well
let's go to the front of the times
because this is also um following on
from that
the prime minister being urged to cut
the isolation time it was 10 days it's
gone down to seven days in the past week
and now they're saying it should be cut
to five days obviously the us have just
done that actually do you think it
should happen and do you think it will
happen here
actually well this would be a risky move
um this would be a risky move but at
this point as i was saying we need to be
wary that our actions to fight the
disease aren't worse than the disease
itself and this is particularly true
when it comes to health care workers who
as another report in the papers today
has said are dropping like flies um and
and by that they mean are testing
positive and then come going out of work
um and it's based on um it would be
reducing the quarantine time to five
days would be following on from the
united states
where the centers for disease control
and prevention have recommended that it
be dropped to five days because of
evidence that they say
shows transmission is most likely to
happen within those five days
two before developing symptoms and three
afterward
and also a lot of cases are asymptomatic
so the idea is if you are testing
negative and you are no longer showing
symptoms you should be able to come out
of quarantine earlier i think five days
is probably a little bit risky but the
idea of looking at the evidence and
thinking seriously about reducing that
time is really important because the
knock-on effects of quarantine are going
to get much worse than the disease as
time goes on and more of the population
is vaccinated
yes ma'am what do you think do you think
we're going to see it cut to five days
oh well i i'm not sure i think um the
way we
we
make decisions about the national health
service workers um it seems to me
extraordinarily um
uncaring they are exhausted they are
falling like flies and i wish to i think
we should ask them
whether five days quarantine or rest as
it would be in their case is really good
enough for them to come back to work and
the other thing i do disagree about with
ashley is that people are sensible and
they know how to take care of themselves
you go on to the london underground they
did agreed over christmas because they
wanted christmas you go on their london
underground the number of unmasked
people is horrendous compared to other
places
scotland wales and and um northern
ireland are taking a more cautious
approach and on new year's eve you will
see a breakdown of all caution so i want
to see what the figures are like after
that
rave that is going to happen
uncontrolled i think
um on the 35th the figures in scotland
and wales aren't exactly encouraging you
know um i i i don't think i think i
think there's a lot of moralization
going on that's starting to depart a
little bit from from the evidence of
what's going actually going on in the
world i think covet has started to stand
for those people who don't do the right
thing and as opposed to us good people
who are careful
sorry they don't wear masks that is a
bad thing
they don't get vaccinated some of them
can't i accept that but look don't tell
me it's moralizing i'm talking about the
health of the nation i think that's
really quite rude to say it's a
moralizing
you know i am not moralizing it i'm
sorry but it i'm sorry if that sounds
rude to you but it is it has become if
you look if you look at the the the
political comics for example of the
unvaccinated
there are obese people wearing red caps
and eating something this is something
that i've noticed
and it's come to stand for those hordes
of
possibly trump voters or even in the uk
you see this with with people with red
caps why they're wearing red they're a
40-something year old man it has become
a proxy for talking about the other
those people who are a threat to the
rest of the the nation and i don't think
that's actually the case if you look at
people who are unvaccinated um they are
not um you know they are they tend to be
ethnic minorities they tend to be people
who are a bit poorer um they're not this
like boogeyman of the white
working class or the trump voter or
something like that but that's what it's
become it has become a symbol of of
morality and being a good upstanding
person against those people okay i i
think this is obviously something we all
have to discuss and um yeah
we're gonna move on now because we're
running out of time but uh yasmine just
talk us through this social care system
um report that's really troubling it's
in the eye in a lot of the papers but
you've picked it out in the eye
yes this is quite interesting and very
worrying um
that a
a report by the by um
on young people young people's lives
has come out with some really shocking
evidence
that
and they've actually said that our
social care system is not fit for
purpose that a lot of young people in
care are moved from
house to house from area to area often
away from
where their support networks are
multiple placements away their social
workers change and they become
exposed at that you know with all this
movement and insecurity
they become very vulnerable and
attracted to
and actually probably groomed by
criminal gangs
and so you know this report is very
worrying and needs to be taken seriously
that you know these children were
already so failed by
families and the system are now ending
up in in
as korean criminals